you have better technology than ever
we're more enlightened than ever why do
we see these up surges or explosions of
very primal tribal conflict let's build
a wall let's keep them out let's have
these people separate from these people
let's make sure that those people never
there's a french paleontologist named
pierre Chardon who wrote about a hundred
years ago and he said that everything
that rises must converge and he
essentially laid out an arc of the
history of the world in the evolution of
the universe and that there are moments
of great conflict on the way to unity
depth and complexity so there's actually
a whole body of thought that if
everybody's in separate tribes but the
whole thing is moving us towards a
global tribe a connection everybody's my
brother and sister the only way for this
tribe to become close connected brother
and sister with that tribe is they're
going to have to interact and when they
interact those first interactions may be
a little dodgy as the Brits would say
there may be some conflict I also think
if you go beyond simply larger
large-scale movement towards complexity
and unity whenever you encounter the
unknown whenever you encounter pain loss
suffering or something different
it will either break you open and you
will be broken open in the best kind of
ways so that you become more expansive
South American Indians have this phrase
they talk about making room within
yourself for the immensities of the
universe so you were always taught that
these people are like this but then one
of those people moves in next door and
you find out they're actually fantastic
they're actually wonderful like the best
neighbor you've ever had then whatever
you were previously taught whatever bias
racism bigotry you now have to redo all
your labels and categories because they
don't work because
flesh-and-blood person has smashed them
to pieces
so this disruption it will either break
you open and you will become more
expansive more inclusive more of an
embrace for the other or the pain of
that disruption you will dig your heels
and you will regress you will build a
bigger wall between the two of you and I
would argue that's what's happening
right now is the world is shifting
really really really fast
if you go back 500 years and let's say
the year 15 what 43 if I were to say to
you 15 years after the invention of the
printing press
what 1443 whatever that is if I were to
say to you hey this book's thing I think
this book's thing could really catch on
we all laugh now because we be like yeah
that book's thing did kind of catch on
and it up ended government Authority
education religion science we're
essentially 15 years into the internet
we're only 15 years into what could
probably is the greatest sort of
technological invention or revolution
and at least 500 years maybe ever so
we're in this time of massive transition
if you would have said to Jeb Bush at
the beginning of the Republican
primaries who had more money stockpiled
than any candidate ever with more name
recognition than any candidate oh by the
way you're gonna get destroyed by a guy
on Twitter we would all said no way that
is the weirdest idea oh yeah a
candidates gonna come along who's not
gonna spend any money he's gonna have no
structure it's gonna have no field
operatives he's gonna tweet we would all
be like no no like that there's a way
it's done and yet that's what happened
so you can already see 15 years in
entire things changing I mean you had
the printing press not long after the
printing press you have people saying
things like hey
by the way I don't think the earth is
the center of the solar system which was
how human beings had seen things for
thousands of years so I think we're in
one of those periods and whenever you
have a disruption all new technology
will bring some form of disruption some
people will be like look at this new
world look at the possibilities let's
figure this out and other people will
dig their heels in they will fight it
they will white-knuckle all the more and
the reason why we know this is true at a
macro level is think about friends of
yours who have been through great
suffering think about friends of yours
who lost a child or went through a
horrible divorce generally people either
become bitter or they become better they
generally close down their heart becomes
harder or all of that pain somehow
softens and breaks them open and they
become more open more expansive they
often respond either by becoming a
victim look what happened to me look at
all the reasons I have to not step into
the fullness of life or they go out into
the world carrying around this wound and
others who have been through what they
have been through they looked them in
the eyes and saved me - and they become
this extraordinary voice for healing and
the exact place of their wound is the
place where all sorts of grace and help
flows through them to others so I think
it's what you're seeing right now is the
world is different in 2008 48 percent I
believe it is of births in America were
two non-whites and at the time a number
of people said this statistic is
important because this will shape the
political future of our country are you
okay with that are you okay with all
this difference in diversity do you see
it as a threat are you saying what
happened to my country or are you saying
look what's happening to my country it
is a threat or it is an invitation to
new possibilities and what we're seeing
right now is two very distinct answers
to that question which have always been
the two responses it's just now amped up
through the roof